of the seven americans treated for ebola
so far
all have survived
right now the only american
still undergoing treatment is dr craig
spencer who contracted the disease
abroad while working to protect others
and we should be saluting his service
and we are focused on getting him the
best care possible as well and our
thoughts and prayers are with him
meanwhile the west african nations of
senegal and nigeria have now been
declared ebola-free that's in part
because of outstanding work
led in many cases by americans working
in coordination with those countries to
make sure that we did not see an
outbreak there
so the point is is that this disease can
be contained
it will be defeated
progress
is possible
but
we're going to have to stay vigilant
and we've got to make sure that we're
working together